die stimmung ist super hallo mein name
ist luca letztlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge sims 4 wir sind hier
immer noch schön in unserem haushalt
zusammen mit max und luca die gerade an
unterhosen und toiletten denken lukas
auf toilette max wartet vor der tür
darauf bist luca fertig ist das ist ja
wundervoll die beide haben eine tolle
beziehung was wir allerdings nicht haben
ist ist allzu viel geld er hat
wahrscheinlich schon den titel gelesen
und ich habe es auch in der letzten
folge gesagt ich euch hier verlinkt wie
könnt ihr spahn klicken oder nach dem
video ermessen anschauen oder jetzt oder
lebt euer leben macht das walross bock
habt ich hab keinen schlaf mal wieder
das ist ja was komplett orchester auf
gefahr im titel steht das bieten
deswegen machen wir das ganze jetzt mal
deswegen habe ich mir hier auch sonst
green schott rausgesucht wo sehr viele
chips drinstehen was sich allerdings
natürlich nicht nachgeschaut habe war
wie ich überhaupt ins kino rein komme
herzlich willkommen auf einem kanal ich
habe keine ahnung von dem was ich hier
mache ich muss wohl steuerung umschalt
zu drücken und dann jetzt kann ich
entschied sein geben wenn ich jetzt
theoretischen marktwert oder 1 gb kriege
ich 53.000 geld habe ich verdiene eine
million zimmer leer uns in einem
einzigen haushalt ja wann ich hab es auf
jeden fall ultralight verdient ich will
auf jeden fall auf zehn millionen hoch
gehen und dann können wir uns ja
vielleicht gleich einfach mal eine geile
villa kaufen
endlich habe
mehr geld kann ich anscheinend nicht
haben da wir jetzt eine million haben
kommen dann dann frisst doch einfach
stellt personal ein alter scheißegal es
gibt auch noch den teams und simpel und
dann kann ich wohl einfach einen sims
eigentlich füge ich damit sind sie bei
ihm wie passiert gerade nichts ich
glaube ich habe jetzt hier wirklichen
pas teams hinzugefügt also wir sind auf
jeden fall gerade fünf stück die sich
hier gerade treffen aber eigentlich habe
ich das ganze eine million mal gedrückt
in etwa ich würde mir eigentlich
unglaublich gerne jetzt eigene villa
oder so kaufen
ich weiß nur nicht wie ich umziehen kann
schaeffler im 2 jetzt habe ich hab das
stelle ich gerade im neuen haushalt
familie trotte die aus max und luca
besteht ziehen weg von johnny und allen
blöden das sind wir
warum ist das denn so laut dass sie ist
der neue platz wo wir wohnen wie wir
sehen sehen sie nichts ist auf jeden
fall schon mal deutlich leiser als unser
letzter wohnplatz wie kann ich denn hier
mal die kamera schwenken ich bin jetzt
einfach mal dem bau modus und ich muss
ehrlich zugeben ich würde mir gerne
einfach ein komplettes haus kaufen wo
mache ich das denn schaltet diesen raum
frei nehmen du level 10 des berufszweigs
interstellarer schmutter der astronauten
karriere erreicht was ein scheiß das ist
doch ultra langweilig wir haben hier
nicht mehr irgendwelche nachbarn hier
sind ja nirgends wo ihr wohnt ja niemand
bei uns wir da vorne keine richtigen
nachbarn hatten habe ich jetzt die
möglichkeit einfach mal griff moment in
dazu spencer king louie szene haben
5 mitbewohner oder wir ziehen einfach
hier in ein eigenes ding
ich würde sagen wir ziehen erst mal zu
der familie meine damen und herren max
und luca sind jetzt familie kim spencer
louis gezogen
die stimmung ist super hier geht's nicht
richtig ach du heilige scheiße
die haben ja eine ultra geile bude man
die gehen einfach irgendwie jetzt ist
max weg ich schaue mir noch unsere
mitbewohner an also das jetzt auf jeden
fall unsere villa des ultra nice dann
haben wir hier noch eine wir haben hier
allgemein ultra vier flüsse und so dann
haben wir ja tatsächlich nur diese eine
villa als mitbewohner wie kann es denn
sein dass die alle dieser scheiß treppe
hochlaufen und dann wie komme ich denn
stockwerk nach oben da sind sie wieder
und jetzt können die nicht mehr auf mich
warten lukas sind die green sich auf
jeden fall super in die familie luca ist
am letzten aufnehmen und max schläft
also das haben wir auf jeden fall super
hingekriegt die haben sogar ein
die haben hier sogar eine terrasse alter
oder die verpackte oma sitzt an ihrem
also mit diesen komischen ebenen hier
muss ich erst einmal klarkommen die oma
zog ballerspiele während ihr mann im
bett kennt was geht ab mit denen aber
endlich ist immer ein bisschen was los
luca spielt einfach tetris maxiq davon
immer noch einschläft ganz schön
luca beobachtet jetzt einfach max war
der neue mitbewohner luke hat ja so gern
erklären der pflicht und er zog auch
noch so wenn du kannst den muffin machen
können deutschen und wenn er danach noch
ich schaue mir rum und wenn er dann auch
dann bin ich auch ja dann brauchst die
solivia langweilig sagt ja nicht mal
irgendwas alles klar alles klar wir
haben im moment erreicht und dem luca
sich jetzt wirklich mal ans klavier
setzt um
das könnte man eigentlich mal videos
veröffentlichen oder wenn das album dann
löwen könnte luca lass es einfach sein
wow ich bin begeistert luca kam ich
dieses komplette
was tust du da man jetzt fragt mich nur
noch ab ich muss einfach
wir sehen uns irgendwann aufhören ich
fand sehr schön dass ich mir wieder
zugeschaut habe wie in der letzten folge
schon gesagt haben diese folge links
neben viel geld geschehen wir am 10
millionen muslime leben konnte wir sind
umgezogen sondern familie aufzuspielen
diese umgezogen seiner neuen familie max
payne schon wieder lukas spielt klavier
ich muss dieses video stellen werden
wenn ihr noch eine folge wollt macht
eine bewerbung